TONIGHT, A NEWLY ELECTED HOUSE
REPUBLICAN IS FACING SERIOUS
QUESTIONS ABOUT HIS RECORD
BEFORE HE EVEN TAKES THE OATH
OF OFFICE.
CNN'S BRIAN TODD IS WORKING THE
STORY FOR US.
BRIAN, THERE ARE SOME GLARING
DISCREPANCIES ON WHAT IS THE
RESUME OF THIS CONGRESSMAN
ELECT, GEORGE SANTOS.
>> CNN AND THE NEW YORK TIMES
HAVE LOOKED EXTENSIVELY AT HIS
STATEMENTS, FILINGS, AND OTHER
RECORDS.
WHAT WAS DISCOVERED IS THAT
MUCH OF WHAT THIS MAN CLAIMS TO
HAVE DONE DOES NOT ADD UP.
VOTERS IN HIS DISTRICT MAY NOT
HAVE GOTTEN THE INFORMATION
THEY NEEDED.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
MY NAME IS GEORGE SANTOS.
>> HE IS YOUNG, LATINO, GAY,
AND A WINNER FOR THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
CONGRESSMAN-ELECT GEORGE
SANTOS'S VICTORY IN THE NEW
YORK DISTRICT COVERING PARTS OF
QUEENS AND LONG ISLAND HELP THE
GOP TAKE A NARROW MAJORITY IN
THE HOUSE THIS FALL.
>> MY PARENTS CAME TO THIS
COUNTRY IN SEARCH OF THE
AMERICAN DREAM.
TODAY, I LIVE THAT AMERICAN
DREAM.
>> BUT TONIGHT, A CNN REVIEW
OWED SANTOS'S STATEMENT AND
RECORDS --
HIS RESUME COULD BE INACCURATE.
THE NEW YORK TIMES FIRST
SUPPORTED, CITING PUBLIC
DOCUMENTS AND COURT EITHER CONTT
SUPPORTED BY EVIDENCE.
>> ONCE YOU STARTED TURNING UP
THINGS, MORE AND MORE THINGS
DID NOT ADD UP.
>> MR. SANTOS --
>> A CNN REVIEW FOUND THE SAME
RECIPIENTS --
HIS BIOGRAPHY SAYS HE WENT TO
--
AND NEW YORK UNIVERSITY, URGING
REPRESENTATIVES FOR BOTH
SCHOOLS TOLD CNN THEY HAD NO
RECORD OF ANYONE WITH HIS NAME
EVER ATTENDING.
HIS CAMPAIGN BIOGRAPHY SAID HE
WORKED AT CITI GROUP AND
GOLDMAN SACHS.
BOTH COMPANIES TOLD CNN THEY
HAVE NO RECORD OF HIS
EMPLOYMENT.
SANTOS CLAIMED HE FOUNDED HIS
OWN CHARITY, FRIENDS OF PETS
UNITED, BUT --
>> ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS I
DID WAS LOOK FOR SOME OF THE
FILINGS BECAUSE HE WAS VERY
SPECIFIC ABOUT BEING A --
WHEN WE WERE NOT ABLE TO FIND
THAT WITH THE IRS --
>> THERE WAS NO GROUP CALLED
FRIENDS OF PETS UNITED.
--
CNN HAS ASKED SAN JOSE FOR
COMMENT, BUT HE HAS NOT
RESPONDED.
HIS ATTORNEY TOLD CNN THE NEW
YORK TIMES WAS ATTEMPTING TO,
QUOTE, SMEAR HIM WITH
DEFAMATORY ALLEGATIONS.
SANTOS IS A DEMOCRATIC OPPONENT,
ROBERT ZIMMERMAN, SAID HIS
CAMPAIGN KNEW ABOUT SOME OF
THESE DISCREPANCIES.
ASKED TODAY BY CNN WHETHER HIS
CAMPAIGN WAS RAISING CONCERNS
LOUDLY ENOUGH --
>> WE SPOKE TO MANY REPORTERS
ON THESE ISSUES AND RAISE THESE
CONCERNS FROM THE HIGH HEAVENS.
AND THAT IS WELL ESTABLISHED.
THE DCCC, DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSIONAL CAMPAIGN
COMMITTEE, BROUGHT OUT A
DOCUMENT ABOUT IT.
--
>> IT IS ABOUT THE MEDIA.
IF YOU ARE A VOTER IN THIS
DISTRICT, THE TRUTH IS, YOU
DON'T REALLY KNOW WHO YOU JUST
VOTED FOR.
>> NOW, AS FOR WHAT COULD
HAPPEN WITH GEORGE SANTOS FROM
HERE, HIS ELECTION OPPONENT,
ROBERT ZIMMERMAN, IS CALLING
FOR A JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
INVESTIGATION AND AN
INVESTIGATION INTO THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
ON THAT FRONT, CNN HAS REACHED
OUT TO HOUSE GOP LEADER KEVIN
MCCARTHY TO ASK FOR WHAT HE
PLANS TO DO ABOUT IT.